no don't encourage this yeah please guys
please let me know this this you guys
are the problem all right we're going to
give him the ego
hello everybody and welcome back to a
very special episode of the unwax
podcast with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine stallone you guys we
did it round of applause episode 15.
thank you thank you so much oh the
studio is clapping yes yes yes
it's been a journey it has been i don't
think we expected to make it to episode
50. no we did not i feel like we see
ourselves a year ago from today and it
was just not the same i think it was us
hauling our ring lights in it was
embarrassing
but we really wanted to make this
episode extra special for you guys
that's why we thought we must bring in a
guest
that has never one done a podcast before
never
is
honestly the hardest guess that we've
ever had to catch quite literally yeah
the sea is pretty big
it took a lot of man you guys we went
fishing for two weeks
to reel this guest in
well maybe you had some holes in your
neck did you ever think of that
perhaps we did why don't we introduce
you right now because clearly you want
to jump into the show already we have
doing his first podcast interview ever
ever the iconic king
shark ladies and gentlemen thank you i'd
like to be known as the pod father from
here on in no
father
about for you to say do a line from a
line also
mike in front of your mouth
thank you okay now i worked for a long
time on that it just doesn't come
naturally dad grab your mic
and put it to your mouth okay i guess
that was a straight yeah okay okay yeah
i guess that was a straight giveaway
dad welcome to the show obviously you
were probably the number one requested
guest that we've had ever that's not
true it is and honestly we wanted to
wait we really were
i think we're very nervous and very
excited because we just want to make
sure that you know our podcast are you
okay you're adjusting
okay
you guys were expecting yeah
come on you guys were probably expecting
something a bit more structured than
this this is gonna be the most chaotic
episode you're ever gonna get what is it
the weather pain like oh you don't need
a weatherman to know which way the wind
blows here it is folks
andy just stand up we wanted to make
sure that before we had you come on
because you know we want to make you
proud we wanted to make sure this
episode this podcast everything was just
perfect and legitimate and legitimate
and i think you know new studio
new couch it seems pretty legitimate
thanks for coming on today well you're
more than welcome i think people are now
starting to realize that you are a
secret comedian no i'm not i just think
that
life
belongs to those who can somehow make a
sick joke out of it all because it does
it works out if you take life too
seriously
what is that old saying to those who
think life is a comedy of those who feel
life is a tragedy so i just try to keep
it light and lively well that's
something that you've always done and
that's
a side to you that i don't think a lot
of people know
and that's why we think this episode
would be a great opportunity to ask you
questions that maybe might be
inappropriate for other interviewers to
possibly ask you but we can get away
with it because we're your daughters
because we're your kids fair enough ask
those questions okay difficult i mean
yeah let's just get into
should we start when you were just a wee
little boy a little boy yeah all right
let's go into your childhood because you
have quite the interesting child yeah oh
if you could describe yourself in three
words growing up what would it be
seriously yeah okay
um
loner
very uh expressive really loud
right going
and
without a doubt um
i'd say i got along very well
conversing yeah but it's almost because
from what you've told us growing up that
you really just had to fend for yourself
you were you're kind of like a feral
straight kid no really i mean your
parents
very strange my my parents weren't
exactly brought up like stellar human
beings either the craziest story i think
one of them was the fact that you two i
mean this is i don't know if anyone
knows this but your parents dropped you
off at like an old folks home when you
were younger for the first time
no you were left in an elderly home so
you were around as a five-year-old
95 year old
you were figuring out how to converse
with people very quickly because you
were able to have these conversations my
average friends were like 90. yeah like
so you're about five years old yeah at
the time i didn't think it was so bad
but we look back on it it's not exactly
a smart choice day care centers you have
daycare centers today back then they
really didn't have they had
uh boarding houses
really yeah for like traveling salesmen
or
airlines stewardesses people coming in
out
so you go down to a boarding table
boarding house yes and you'd see 11
strangers the next day there's nine
strangers
it's a boarding house literally like low
rent yeah
you know
you got some guy who smells like turkey
room
yo can't wait till he moves on to get
that
guy smelled like crab back in here he
was great oh my god i mean that probably
makes sense for why you like jello so
much today is that's probably all you
were eating in the old days i do i like
food that doesn't require too many
intelligence rice pudding and jello
exactly
applesauce
you know
so since five years old you're left with
strangers you told us countless times
the amounts that you've ran away from
home i remember a lot i remember one
time actually i don't know if you
remember this we were in philadelphia
maybe
four years ago together it was just you
and me
and we were just walking through the
streets and you were getting nostalgic
and you were telling me all these
stories and you stopped me on the street
corner and you said
right here i was 13 years old when i ran
away from home and i lit my first
cigarette on this corner right here in
phoenix
i don't know why i thought that was the
coolest story ever my dad's smoking a
cigarette at 13. but you were really
nostalgic about it and i think that's
isn't it funny how certain things that
get burnt into your memory like certain
things that are just apocalyptic in your
life oh my first cigarette which i
remember very well as a parliament
not it was parliament
new filter types like whoa
so you get to die a little bit later you
know that kind of thing before then
cigarettes are not considered bad
because they're very cool right so
everyone by the time they were 12 or 13
had some pack rolled up in their
shoulder yeah it was trendy it was yeah
right it was terrible
i mean how many times did you run away
from home oh my god
literally uh
at least a dozen or more but it was
never planned
for example this is what's so different
why i would hate to have raised myself
i could have never done it i would put
myself up for adoption but i don't blame
you i mean no seriously i believe i'm no
picnic
i had this uh intention disorder kind of
a thing i just didn't
focus on anything so anything that would
become
routine or boring i would leave so i
become on my way to school
16 years old
like oh god
i don't go to florida i want to go to
florida and literally start hitchhiking
to florida starting at roosevelt
boulevard in philadelphia no money in
other words whatever i had for lunch
and a coat
which i'd end up selling
outside of a swamp in ocala florida for
three bucks which i remember that was my
that saved me that three bucks was
really important but yeah that's what i
would do and then you get to the bottom
you get to florida and okay now what i
have to get arrested
or something
because i have to get back to
philadelphia no one's going to volunteer
which you did you'd purposely get
arrested so then they'd send you home
what type of because you were a minor
what would you do to get around so
clever thank you
what would you do
well what happened
the dumbest thing was if this goes this
doesn't bode well for our military
either so i'm in ocala florida
alone
and i just sold my cup for three bucks
and i said i got okay i have enough for
a meal but i gotta get back to
philadelphia and i see a military base
and i break onto the military base but
it's so simple it's like really
literally how is that simple yeah it's
it's a it's a fence it's like not like
complicated wasn't like oh sirens guys
with machine guns it's like oh my gosh
like you expect a guy with a lawnmower
behind you going
come on in
so i went in yeah place is deserted
maybe 10 o'clock at night
then there's a thing called the px which
is where it's kind of like a
place you go to eat yeah buy cigarettes
i wish i go in there
of course everything's locked up except
oatmeal
this is why i have such an affinity for
oatmeal
any soft food well
the thing is you never
ever
put oatmeal in your mouth
dry
oh you guys heard it here first on the
unwaxed podcast make sure you do not eat
dry ever
i was hungry i said okay look at oatmeal
this sounds great quaker oaks guy on the
box no
how dangerous can it be huh it looks
funny
yeah just like that and by the time i
brought it back
oh god that was so jammed up it was so
dry you know it became like sponges i
started choking to death so you're
choking on an oatmeal
in a military base a military base in
ocala florida right left right and they
came in
and i go thank god and do they arrest
you and thank god for oatmeal thank you
they arrested you and saved you yes they
did
okay so
you were quite the menace as a kid such
a menace that you tell us countless
stories of how you were kicked out of
13 schools was it 13 or 14 13. 13
schools they would have made 14 but they
ran
schools so but they weren't regular
schools obviously well military schools
schools for trouble yeah you have to
work your way through
again in all fairness to myself
okay i wasn't raised in a right way no
way my brain has always been flipped
sideways it's just the way i've
interpreted life that's why now i
realize i made the right choice
but back then you were a menace
right
you were going nowhere you were what is
known as a juvenile delinquent jd he
puts that in questions that was a
delinquent that's right you are a jd
so that's when i realized earlier on
after they kept sending me to school
after school after school
he just doesn't fit in i go guys they're
like the seventh school right where do i
fit in he goes i don't know
then we tried it again and they said he
just doesn't fit in and we're not gonna
allow him back he's such a disruptive
force
we won't let him back into the state of
pennsylvania what did you do
and maryland it was banned from the
entire maryland school board what
montgomery hill it's not it's not you
just having atd in class to get that
that is pretty bad no i was that was
adventurous
do you remember the story you told me
about you going to military school and
stealing knives from
your
what would you call your captains or
your officers officers
so was that the factor that caused you
to not even be able to go to school i
said how do i get out now i'm in a
school
where everyone's
very physical yeah they all look like
they're grown men with full beards i
mean they're like 16 17 years old but
they're they've been there and this is
the place to get you in order
but you're right so they took these kids
there from the time they were eight and
they'd be there until they're 18 so when
they came out at 18 they were tough wow
i mean tough there was no love lost this
is when you had corporal punishment you
take a kid in the back room and just
smack the hell out of that that's what
it was at this point this school is for
troubled kids that need
it's military school you're still at
military school here yeah and this is
the craziest part not even in the
troubled school yet
anyway you know this all this stuff is
happening these kids are getting hit and
they're getting corporal punishment but
you still find the need
to steal stuff
and so you get that same punishment
knowing that that could happen that's
why i think it's some it's just yes i
think there's something to be said about
a certain mentality that when you're
told not to
right away you say ah that's for normal
people i can pull this one off yeah i
can do it it's like a stupid dare like
oh what are you chicken
jump off a building no i'll try it no
you're just stupid well no that's that's
human behavior exactly right you're not
allowed to go out they're gonna sneak
out that's my point so i had that over
developed sense of competition if you
say no
that's just well that definitely plays
into your character today i think a lot
oh yeah just when you say no you mean
yes that still plays every conversation
everything we have after
you know what i think is so interesting
too
just like you have that cigarette story
you keep um your report card from high
school as well and you show you show it
all the time you have it i use it as an
example why do you use a nice example
because it shows that you can fail every
class yeah
and still end up pretty good right so
but you didn't fail every class every
class no you didn't fail art class well
art
yeah but that's you're an artiste it
makes sense well
if you saw the picture it was a horse
with flies going around his head it
wasn't exactly
matisse yeah i'm not gonna lie we do
have one of your sketches framed from
when you were 15. and i go up to mom i'm
like why is this up like just because
you know a kid paints it doesn't mean i
mean i'm i'm not gonna insult your work
it's good you are insulting it it's good
but you know it's it was it was just
like oh you passed insult about 15
minutes ago
now we're into like yes no you know no i
think can i actually have all my photos
now we're boarding on a lawsuit
okay
for right deprivation character here oh
oh i mean the knot should be issued
every single day between all three of us
i think the craziest uh schooling you
had which is we had this discussion for
a really long time that we wanted to
make this into a tv show like a horror
show was your time at devereaux and this
is a school if anyone knows what it is
it's in massachusetts or it was i don't
know if it's still around and it's a
school for troubled kids like behavioral
issues and i think that was like the
final straw for every schooling that was
that was it
i can't believe we're bringing that up
you know it's a very
well we don't have to get into it that
deep we don't but but it's fine
perverse it's just a school where you
never go home right so give listeners
maybe context how how this would be
different from a okay they take you at a
certain yeah they test you
and
some some people are sent there by the
state but you have to have a certain
pension iq for something
you can't just be a horrible human being
you have to have like some shining grace
something right and
i don't know they found it in art but
that school was so strict and so
difficult that
anytime you had a problem you're dealing
with another 25 kids in your class every
one of them had severe like violent
problems or they came from home where
they had
seriously ish serious issues uh between
their parents and them just odd and
when you would become
truants now you lived there god but if
you were late for classes that or you're
flirting with a girl
they would take you to a place called
well it was called byberry one time
no but it's called park lodge and park
lodge
was a building where they would send
lifers to and lifers a person that never
gets out it was a stained asylum yeah
pretty much insane
it's insane and i'm going what am i
doing insane assignment all i was doing
was talking to a couple of kids but they
were using that to this yeah
from how old did punish you yeah well
how old were you 16. so you were
flirting with girls at this behavioral
school and to punish the students they
would like have them go as a retreat one
week two weeks three weeks
no way into a padded cell yeah that's so
raw oh it's so wrong
until you've been there and you're with
people that are
in that situation for life again girls
this is in the 60s
and the world is a different place
there's a whole different place back
then corporal punishment was normal
there was guys would walk around there
with all the fellas there were lifers
and a lot of them couldn't talk if you
ever saw the film
cuckoo's nest yeah that's a joke very
nice movie right but it's a almost a fun
place it's not fun so the point being i
would go through that and you come back
into the normal school system and
supposedly you learn something not
really that much then i realized that
people's human nature is pretty well set
up at an early age
and as long as you're not innately cruel
or doing things that are incredibly
vindictive to individuals i never saw
myself as anything other than you know
misunderstood music like everyone else
feels and looking for my place in the
world so it was never what you call like
an incorrigible horrible human being
that was looking to rob or steal or hurt
i was looking at anything just mischief
yeah you were anything to get out of
anything to get out of schooling right
right
so yeah and that's what you did and i
want to touch on the fact that you said
you just did what you could to survive
because i feel like that's been your
entire life's journey so far yeah so you
make it out of devroe you're now a young
adult and i would love to sort of get
into your early career because you have
probably the most abnormal resume i have
ever heard in my life i mean just to
name a few you were a lion cage cleaner
a bouncer you cut fish you were an usher
good fish
i want to get into that
book salesman why were you a volleyball
coach in switzerland oh i have to say
something i was i was actually i was in
new york last week yeah and there was a
man cutting fish and i don't know i
stopped in the street and i said to
myself my dad used to do that that's
right
but but what do you what how were you a
fish cutter i was such a good fish
cutter i i don't but i have a hard time
believing i'm serious your mother was
with me am i right
we went to look at a home someone had
for sale and the guy was maybe 85 years
old he goes i know you
you used to cut the best fish always
dover delic am i lying
i believe you you could read through it
i was for some reason some reason me and
friendship you and fish
of course you get complaints everyone ah
it's not thick enough but yeah i would
do that and just do a lot of these odd
jobs because i thought
if i do all these horrible jobs at night
it would leave the day open to go out
and pursue
my alleged career
and nothing was happening so i would
take any random job from bodyguards to
this to chasing people to chasing people
yeah i would chase people out of
bookstores if they robbed if they were
up yeah they don't change so through all
of these oddball jobs odd jobs did you
get fired from many of them everyone
okay which one were you the best out
there i was fantastic at being an usher
why actually i can see that because
people oh it's an usher i said no you
don't get it
usher i can go to class eight hours a
day and watch a film
how it's broken down how it's written
how it's truly
uh
constructed and deconstructed because i
watch it every day and i started taking
notes and i became really good at
understanding editorial right yeah and
we ended up winning an oscar for best
edition
was that your introduction to that was
my introduction to it yeah so i thought
okay let me just take this horrible job
but i know there's a plan there isn't
like okay i
i went to four years of college to
become an usher no i went to four years
of college to eventually
do something in the arts right and i
said here it is this is a no-brainer so
at that point when you were in usher and
you're watching the film and you're
breaking it down in your head were you
wanting to be an actor or were you
wanting to be a screenwriter editor
director all right the acting was i'm
starting to realize this is never going
to happen people are saying oh you have
a speech impediment your mouth is
crooked you slur and i got somebody
something i don't know
i know that they said well it's just not
going to work maybe you'll be an extra
so i started to buy into that you know
hmm
because every time i was cast
it was always for a thug yeah can you
imagine i always thought i'd be like
hugh grant is like i selling book
there's a love interest yeah
what are you saying no for over there
mom's saying no
come on you married me it had to be
something okay
she's so shy she thinks you're funny i
know she doesn't think i'm funny
show up a heart attack oh yeah
my wife is the shyest person you know
what you've always said to us though was
that um no matter what we do in life
always learn how to write
because
regardless of anything because i mean
that's what kind of i guess yeah you
don't have to be a good writer exactly
you just have to write and and
eventually that'll
your inner thoughts will come to the
surface and take care of themselves
to be a gifted writer it's it's freakish
like you can be a really gifted actor in
a terrible writer terrible director you
don't have to know what your niche is
so anyway
acting i realized i was always going to
play the thug i was always going to be
the mugger
i was always beating up woody allen or
beating up jack lemmon or beating up
who's the guy that played david
carradine
actually david carrington beat me up
that's when i realized i said enough is
enough
i can't i can't take it anymore in death
race 2000
and that's when i started to focus on
the written word
and i was not very good i was
i would like to talk about the fact that
you just said that you're never good
because people
tend to pursue careers or hobbies
at things that they know they're good at
or at least they think that they're good
at but writing is one of those things
that either you go to school and you're
taught how to do it or you're just
naturally gifted and and that's
something that just pours out of you
but you're saying i knew i wasn't a good
writer so what made you continue to
write because i never passed an english
course in other words when you say good
writer i use that terminology and you
understand the inner workings and outer
workings of the english language in
other words you understand how to
deconstruct and construct a sentence how
to diagram a sentence i don't know what
a pronoun is an adjective
not me but you don't need to know i
understand but
you do they do teach you that you need
to know that people will grade you then
you go to college you're turning your
term paper and you've turned it in the
way i turn it in they say you're an
idiot
but
but the difference is
it's the way people speak how did you
teach yourself then i just just an ear
did you read a lot was it like i did i
did read a lot i i didn't read when i
was in college and then i started when i
was broke
i would spend hours in the new york
library
just looking for subject matter or
something and then eventually i came
across edgar allan poe
and i said
what do i have to do with this guy
nothing zero a he's a stone genius he's
a poet laureate he's an incredible
writer and i mean he would have been the
most amazing director you know was he he
didn't have that visual
is he what changed everything for you
but here's what changed me folks
is when you start to get something
that's out of your wheelhouse
for example writing about poe i was no
longer writing about what i did last
summer or my adventure or how i got
along with my mother it was about
another subject
so now i became a writer
about another subject so you became an
investigator he became yeah more you're
exploring in other words you became a
vehicle for writing that's not just
about you
yeah like you'll see some things like
woody allen he'll do
80 of his material
is him right about his life
that's what he does and he does it well
whereas i thought no i'm never going to
get out of this until i start writing
about someone else's life and that was
the beginning of poe and then from poe
i did a thing called cheerful charlie
which is an incredible story about
you've written over 45 screenplays
so did you
going off of what you just said
was writing
outside of your wheelhouse writing about
people and and stories that weren't
about you was that sort of an escape
from your own yeah it was you know
especially writing female parts
like when you write adrian people go oh
rocky rocky's not a if rocky if someone
says rocky's a sports film again i want
to wait why does that upset you yeah
because it's not what is it sports film
clear it up right now
what is rocky is a love story about a
guy who's a broken down fighter that's
all it is right it's never about money
it's never about oh i became champion oh
i want to be champion i just put
something together so you love edgar
allan poe his brain his love stories his
emotions and then you always used to
tell us you used to look up to hercules
as a physical
being do you think that's like a
combination of the two with rocky oh my
god it is
great think about it because
hercules is he didn't he go from like
zero to hero
and then you have edgar allan poe who's
like immensely in love with this what
was it um penelope what was her name
annabelle
ah
maybe i just unlocked something that you
didn't even realize so you're saying
because
i like hercules and i like poe
you've just discovered something yeah
well i realize that's rocky no but i
think you might have hit on something
because you were saying that i think
that's what something even that i do i
think even system does and a lot of
people do is
to sometimes see like a better version
of themselves they start to create a
different character in you right you
probably saw i mean is that how you
started rocky did you always love boxing
before no no it's okay i just saw it as
a very very easy sport to figure out do
you think that's
easy i mean it's pretty simple
and then you realize how much skill goes
into it which is extraordinary and it'll
also add the
life and death aspect of it
but
boxing
i realize people
are obsessed with two things in life
racing and boxing in every aspect oh you
gotta race to beat the club you gotta
race you get your thing on time where
you get your tax returns race race race
race race you get your finals on it's
always
going somewhere time is up so and people
will bet on how fast this phone falls
this i mean anything
nothing's off limits for for racing for
time
and i thought okay what's the other
thing that everyone relates to
symbolically fighting
as soon as a guy walks into the room he
slides up another guy's oh how would i
last against him
i mean everything is a competitive
mm-hmm and then it gets down to you
realize [ __ ]
life is a big battle man there's like
there's no flat spots jesus you solve
one problem then you got another one you
got this job then you got a terrible
relationship we got a good relationship
but it falls apart
one thing after another
fighting so i thought if i could write a
story
that deal with a guy that deals with a
guy who's a slumpy guy who on the
outside looks like a real tough guy
should maybe have it together he has
nothing together yeah and and people can
relate to that yeah because he doesn't
even think of himself as tough he's just
a loser and he admits he's a loser
there's so much that people can relate
to within the film and
i think that aside from it being a love
story obviously it highlights the
message of not giving up and people
really resonate with that and i think a
lot of you know fans of yours don't know
or maybe they do if they're a true fan
don't know
how
strong that message is held even before
rocky or while rocky was being written
because for example your living
situation as you were writing rocky
i mean you said that you would have
newspapers on your walls to keep you
warm like what were you what was your
living situation as you were writing the
first rock you painted the windows black
to focus yeah i did paint in black
because i don't know what time it didn't
matter
what time it was you know so oh you got
to get oh it's time for breakfast right
away you've just you derailed yourself
right i'll i'll have breakfast but i'm
hungry i don't need to know what time it
is that kind of thing so i was trying to
eliminate all the excuses because it's
hard to write and you're looking for any
reason please
someone call that's why i took the phone
out so you couldn't be called so you
were straight focused painted black one
of those
black windows and it was a two-way phone
but that actually makes a lot of sense
because even today when you're writing
and you go into your zones and i know
mom knows this for a fact
you'll
wake up at around two in the morning
and then you'll go back to bed around
seven in the morning
i mean your schedule is crazy but i
didn't know that you would do that even
when you were writing rocky and that's
really clever well i don't know if it's
clever it just seems like
that's just writing style i think
somewhat of a genetic
dispensation to have this kind of
the writing gives it to you it's kind of
like a gift that it will tell you when
to write when not to write but writing
i'll tell you right now is a miserable
means of existence it is terrible is
there anything you like about no there's
nothing
you love you love the end result you
love the fact that you have it on paper
i respect writing and believe it but the
process itself and i've discussed this
with so many writers look at writers
they look it's true ready to kill
themselves yes they're all worn out
they're tired they live in their own
heads
like psychologically they're torn to
shreds because they can never be in the
moment they can never be in this right
now if i was writing a screenplay i'd be
going i said i'm working oh yeah hi
hello
but i'm still going god i gotta say you
said to you so you're torn like that and
that's why a lot of uh alcoholics i mean
uh writers become alcoholic right right
they do well i'm sure not knowing what
time it was for you would definitely
spun you out in a bad way
but obviously it worked out because how
you wrote the scripture
three days yeah four days three days no
no i thought it was a it was a four days
three and a half days three and a half
oh i thought it was a week no because
again i tell young people that want to
be writers don't get so hung up on the
perfection
know that 90 of it is garbage
the fact that you got through
that's amazing that you actually got a
beginning middle and then no matter how
flawed that's the hard part because 90
of the writers they go up to about page
80 and they burn out
page 90 burn out they don't have that
finale if you happen to have an any man
you're home free how did you feel going
from being literally a kid kicked out of
13 schools selling your dog all the
stuff having barely any money to scrape
by to
instant stardom
it's it's kind of shocking because
they're in lies a terrible attribute
that people actually it's a character
flaws not an attribute where you tend to
seek out
revenge
i told you so i told you so i told you
so so now you become a bit more
belligerent
i warned you this is that and it's like
a fighter after having won a victory
you're standing over your opponent like
this you know you don't need to do that
you want you're knocked out you proved
your point
that's that to me was my biggest
problem
and it took years to work that out
because right you open your mouth up and
you burn a few bridges and
that was foolish were you applying that
i told you so towards
agencies movie studios or was it just
the world mostly critics critics
okay mostly critics is that you couldn't
do it this and that or there's certain
ways that you come into this business
and i came in a very obtuse way so i
wasn't exactly everyone's favorite i'm
like an anomaly
so
i didn't work my way up in other words
some actors say oh de niro did this and
petrino went to that clay and he
yeah they worked their way up they
earned it
right and so they said you didn't earn
it well they said i just put it this way
who is this guy you know like where did
he come from what are his credentials
he's okay i guess for an amateur that
kind of a thing no it's all right i i
get it i get it it's no big deal that's
what sells papers but
the point is
you're supposed to
hopefully
just let it go because you've got the
you won you got the prize
if you sit there and flaunt it that's
what's really horrible and that's what
like a lot of guys make that and i see
it happening and i go oh man i want to
give this guy a call and say just
take your win and leave don't sit there
and grind and make these critics a fool
and that critics are full and it's not
true it's just that's not how the
business works listen you've had critics
since
they were doing plays of antigone back
in you know ancient
greece it's always been that way but i
don't know if you learned that lesson
until later on in life i probably
haven't i'm probably just talking crap i
haven't learned it at all i think what
exactly what you're saying right now i
think you do right now 100
but were you that way
when you
were by the rocky iv comes along you're
already known you're already famous but
are you still
having that sort of attitude of saying
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying so when
did you realize what age did this
realization i think when you almost lose
it i had a real down period say around
95 when i did complain 95 96
and i said oh let me do something really
off
you know off my out of my comfort zone
and i did it and
i was very happy with the project but
actually it set me way back
why it just
the studios are going why would you do
that man you did that for nothing why
would why would you just do an action
film i said because i was gonna do it i
was going to do an action film next i
was just trying to prove a point to
myself and whoever cared he go well that
doesn't make us look good because you're
doing this for free and why would we pay
you anyway it began a very bad spiral
for about eight years
eight years did you write anything in
between that no i mean i couldn't
imagine as a very successful actor not
working what does that do to an actor's
ego
jennifer do you want to ask my wife
about that what do you what do you think
mom
well i'm not probably can't hear me but
it was it was um we had sophia and then
we had you sistine so i just
stayed being a mom she stayed busy i
stayed neurotic he stayed neurotic we
just kind of left him in the movie
theater watching films all day
for years and years and years and years
i said you know i'm going to try to make
one last rocky
and nobody wanted to do it the producer
said over my dead body it's never going
to happen it was really it's a real
wake-up call yeah yeah noah no one
wanted to do it and we happened to be in
a restaurant one night and we met a
fellow who
named joe
and
you should admit great you know joe yeah
anyway uh i don't get him in trouble or
anything right
so
he goes yeah it's a great it sounds a
good story bring it on over so i brought
over it
because my wife know you guys the
screenplay my wife read it and she cried
and went
down
now we're there now we're in mom
brought you back from the dead of 16
yeah she's cheering because she knows
she did hold on
jennifer was the one that created rocky
balboa well she
started the introduction which therefore
created
my mom sent the script over to the wife
right mom well i sent the script to joe
you didn't do anything
ah ah but okay mama so i'm every strong
man is a stronger woman
all right i'll give her a credit but
i have a question what was the worst
film you've done and what was your
favorite film to do
worse film rhinestones just kidding that
was my favorite you installed for my
no listen i had fun on that movie you in
in in chaps with dolly parton were you
kidding me that's your peek that was i
feel like that is actually who you
are no i think that's closer to whoever
i'm saying people think he's more rambo
you're way more rhinestone yeah way more
or oscar when you tried to do coffee oh
my god awesome that's funny you're
you're a funny guy in life i don't know
if comedy is your thing
well there's another thing i think you
built a certain kind of image yeah and
like if clint eastwood came in here
right now and did one of the great
comedy routines no look at it see
already going i don't know i'd be afraid
to laugh because he may shoot me
that's the point but i feel like that's
what people feel like that they do
they do they do so i have to realize
you're not exactly the comedic type
looking you just don't fit that thing so
therein lies the issue right yeah so but
it took a few comedies to figure that
out and
even though i love comedies it was a
disaster
wow you're also savant honestly this guy
knows everything about everything he'd
probably tell you where this couch was
built i know that couch is built yeah
right outside of italy there are no
couple
a buck tooth brothers who make no but
you know it's crazy
he may not know how to fix my mom is
probably the one that will know how to
fix like the pool heater or whatever but
you'll know
where what year
michelangelo did a painting or
i would say mom is more the hands on
deck and then dad's more of the uh
yeah sporadic intelligence it helps you
know we're not bathroom reading you'd be
surprised after a while you're an
encyclopedia yeah he does have like he
does have like 16 books next to his
toilet yeah have you ever seen it he has
like that
you have a library card you're going to
like literally has like stacks of books
next to it that's so funny that's why
you spend so much time well maybe i use
it for toilet paper did you ever think
of that level
okay you know what i honestly think that
if rocky was never written and
imagine your life then right
i think you'd be a stand-up comedian i
don't because listen you push the
envelope
he does he says things that are
inappropriate but funny and people
relate i've been on i've been on good
behavior today i know you have i know
this is really
something you'd be good at that for sure
i know but i think there's so many
better people at it
yes i mean yes
i mean
first of all to be a great comedian
it's
it's a lot of work and there's a lot of
darkness yeah and it's a lot of spending
your time home feeling miserable
you got to turn that into somehow a
comedy routine you did that for eight
years i know i get it i enjoy it okay i
enjoy it but you just can't turn around
and change something that's been around
for 50 years
yeah like all of a sudden we're now
changing this mayonnaise and this will
be
fruit gums
mayonnaise no it's fruit gums from now
on you're just not gonna all of a sudden
switch something so drastic like that
but you know that's i think we're if you
guys are wondering why we have a show
called unwaxed a lot of our personality
and i think our sense of humor does come
from you we have a very raw dry humor
and that's probably why we're still
extremely single is because no one can
take it seriously also you do scare them
but
at the same time i think that loving
happiness is overrated girls it doesn't
happen so what should we expect yeah i
want you to have misery and it's
solitude funny though because when you
when we were growing up you would always
tell us as young girls that we weren't
allowed to get married until we were 45.
i think that's and i honestly believed
that yeah until i was about i still
believe in it yeah what is wrong with it
i think it's a great idea still yeah
why what's the rush i get no rush but
45. well i'll tell you why because at
one time 45 was
your life expectancy and you've already
had about 11 kids at 45.
[Applause]
that's pretty much it okay okay okay but
how was it being in a household full of
girls because now you are with literally
even all girl dogs except buster or one
dog like was it like how is it like how
is it with all girls in the house oh god
it's like being in a cuisinart
head first just lowered into like when
you when you're trying to break down ice
cubes okay but there must be there's
just that noise it makes is there
anything you like yeah come on
about you guys no no no
yeah i guess anything or am i no i love
my girl listen listen i love my girls
they're they're almost almost trouble
free
they've been nothing but a pleasure they
inherit luckily from their mother their
morality and their sense of humor
i guess you might say
yeah but i think i think what's funny
and a lot of people don't know is
although you have three daughters
it's always you know i guess with mom
it's always four against one you raised
us like
macho men yeah and
it's so interesting whenever i tell the
story to people they truly don't believe
me so i guess it might be better coming
from you but when we were in middle
school from maybe second grade to
high school yeah you would wake us up
every day at 6 00 a.m for sure we'd have
to go downstairs
push-ups sit-ups clean
clean jerk dead lift throw shot put
you're in the army now no but we guys
guys guys we had a little four pack when
we were in middle school and i wish i
was kidding like four packs genuinely
look at our like photos when we're
wearing bathing suits we had abs because
of
not only that you made us
recite poetry every single day into a
tape recorder every single day and that
was the thing is what i liked about the
way you raised us was none of my
girlfriends could possibly relate to it
because their dad would do normal dad
stuff whereas like what what is normal
dead stuff normal like let me touch your
peanut butter and jelly into four oh my
gosh where's you that's it how about
some flapjacks girl that's really what
i'm saying what i can tell them is that
they cannot relate to you at all is did
your dad make you speak uh into a tape
recorder and recite poetry and works now
we know the raven by part
but one other one do you know that was
so great anyway i wanted them to
articulate and hit these words known as
plosive sounds like
and so you put a piece of uh i don't
know
[Applause]
every day he would tape a napkin to her
forehead so she had his napkin taped to
her nose and
they learned to be so loud loud yeah and
very dramatic yeah it was nice what was
going through your
so with the workouts in the morning
because i wanted someone to do it for me
and i said okay i would like this i
would like this
for sure who wouldn't want we weren't
allowed to do any other field sports
except shot put no i wanted your girls
to do something that you would be called
upon
never to do but when you do you would be
ready
but guess what i broke the record at
school so you did actually she they were
there was eight events and you won seven
of them and they pulled you out of the
eighth one no we were definitely raised
as full-on tomboy well i just thought
it'd be interesting to take them and put
you into sports
that normally aren't
akin to women yeah like traveling
shut foot boxing power lifting but you
know what was funny is that you were so
into us doing sports and anything
physical activity that any time it was
involving school mom was out of town if
she was working you wouldn't drive us to
school for that week yeah this was by
the way one of my favorite memories with
you
by far mom was always on the road
working
and whenever she would leave
you actually taught me what hooky was in
the fourth cookie is it and i said once
hooky i remember we were driving past my
school
and
the top was down it was raining and you
didn't care the rain was coming into the
car yeah i had my school uniform on the
gates were closed because we were about
four hours late to school
and we just kept driving i said the
school's right here and you go no do you
know what hooky is and i said no and he
goes we're about to go on the best
adventure of your life and so every time
mom would go out of town i'd be like
it's time for hooky and we can just
explore and have so much i'm a big
believer that you can learn more out
there
than you can
sometimes in the classroom so i learned
whatever i learned
while i'm here i learned out there isn't
it so fascinating what a kid will
remember like that it is that is amazing
because i would have thought you would
have ratted me out and said no trying to
be good too i just remembered something
that was horrible they used to do do you
remember for four years we believed that
he was an american idol that was rude i
told kids in my class i told everybody
in my class you were so it was we were
watching american idol and you were like
i was do you remember this mom we came
into the room i think we're in fifth
grade and we were watching it and you
were like yeah you know i was on it we
go no and he goes yeah yeah no they
didn't want me to continue because i was
too good
and we've yeah guys it's true you i you
idolize your dad like you you're we're
daddy you are the greatest guy we told
for literally four years we believed
that they just didn't air it i don't
know why we didn't question that and
then all of a sudden you like you came
up to us and we brought it up to someone
and you were like you actually believed
that yeah yeah was sad but i knew it
wasn't true when one girl came up to me
and said you're a liar and i was in
second grade i go no my dad doesn't lie
to me that's right yeah you did no you
did your big time
but it's okay
she's a liar there chris yeah
but you were you were really you'll find
her
if opposite day was a person that's you
i mean it was ice cream for breakfast
pancakes for dinner well you know it
sounds like like the beginning of a good
movie here like right daddy yeah at the
end daddy's day off here i never fuel
her it's so funny because every time i
think about even when it comes like
marriage or proposal i don't think
you're gonna be the dad that's gonna sit
there going a guy like asking for your
hand in marriage i cannot see you
sitting there seriously going yes sir
this is what god would do he'd put out
his hand and you'd pull his finger and
make a fart joke yeah that literally
would do that's what you would do i
gotta see where he's like how was he
gonna handle stress
oh god oh he's like no seriously girls
these guys will come on they'll say
everything like they'll they'll be the
most perfect individual on the planet
until
that day when you because you really
don't know anyone until you've gotten
into a serious
argument
then you understand what a person is
made up are they forgiving are they not
are they uh explosive are they
gentle
learn a lot i actually am learning a lot
from you because you are i would say
more involved
in my dating life than most sponsorships
or daughters or guys like the guys that
we date realize no they don't realize
that every time i break up with them
it's actually sly breaking up without me
like none of it is my words whatsoever
he's written every breakup text i don't
feel sorry about one of them by the way
and they always give a great response i
do have to say
for some reason you are savant when it
comes to dating for millennials it's
actually amazing you really are he i
know
no no you know how to get rid of guys we
also know how to like us to trick them
into falling in love with us too you're
like i can tell you what you're not
supposed to do that's why why can't you
do that because i tell you i don't think
you should lead people on if you're not
into it then don't be into it it's true
you are very
one thing you were really instilled in
us is safety
don't lead people on because that's when
people snap yeah and you don't want that
i have a question what do you think of
the guys that we've dated
losers oh dad come on
yeah they're not shaking her and going
come on they're nice i'm only kidding
guys i'm just doing this for the benefit
of the microphone
you know what's funny though no
they've been very nice guys they really
have and i'm you know
i do not believe in all of you
mom's giving them the death card to just
say this they are nice guys right
mom loves them she sits at 2 a.m
the first i i love this story because
this i think is like the first true
experience i've ever had i was the first
to have a boyfriend or anything and i
think that
when you're the guinea pig you never
really know what to expect when you
bring a boyfriend home and this is in
high school and i brought my high school
boyfriend over for the first time
meeting the parents
and do you remember what you did to him
when he you shook his hand yeah
yeah sort of it was tight you you were
tight you gripped it yeah and after you
said
next time shake my hand like a man oh
well i was a little carried away but yes
dad he was 17.
he was tall for his age though no he
wasn't sure he was short
every time we bring a guy over i tell
them before they go through the front
door please just grip my dad's hand hard
because for some reason he'll test you
right there and like that'll tell him
listen i'm i'm only joking your
boyfriends you scared the [ __ ] out of
them you know actually that's not true
these guys are big guys
i was getting dropped off for a date one
time right yeah it's my third day
i don't know maybe i was 19. i was
hoping for perhaps a kiss at the end of
the night
and
relax from him
not from me
look
and i look up no he looks up we're
outside our house listen listen to the
story you're ruining my story
who's the jump bag
you thought i was going to do that
gross even listening to what you're
saying listen sort of really
kiss him all right i'm gonna start over
okay he pulls up our driveway ah right
perhaps
the date and myself might kiss go he
looks up and goes holy [ __ ] is that your
dad
and he looks up on the balcony on the
second floor the lights are pitch black
except you have one light in your
bathroom coming behind you so it's just
a black silhouette of you standing
looking over down and he
got in this car
and that was last time i saw him he
never came back he never called me back
after that come on and i always say i
always call him that was the one that
got away dude you actually i always say
you literally turn into king shark you
say one word to these guys you go um no
he didn't have to say anything you're
like the grim reaper over there in the
corner do you think it's harder to
satisfy me or sofia
you i mean no no no no you you you you
yes time
what would you say
sophia jennifer thank you mother said
sofia that's obvious okay i don't think
it's bad to have high standards okay now
it's high standards it was difficult now
it's high standards it was picky it was
height now i'm not hard to take because
yeah no it's oh well okay okay you and
mom have been together i mean married
for 25 years but been together for 35
yeah two three yeah what do you think is
like the secret to keeping that long
version she's the greatest
she is
smiles a lot
she can't help her though she keeps
covering her teeth and it doesn't help
because her teeth are longer than her
her teeth are longer than her fingers so
i stick out like that
it's like an elephant trying to cover
his tusks like that's the thing it's
like you constantly roast her you wrote
me
like oh i love her but her teeth she's
too nice to come in my little piano like
dad so what is this
what do you think it is i don't know i
just enjoy her company i just she's so
fun in a in a naive way because she
actually means what she's saying yeah
that's what i think is so funny you
always say this you always say that mom
is the only person that you've had in
your entire life that you can hang out
with every single day
you're like the only person i don't get
annoyed with after that's true right no
she doesn't tell you this part she hides
[Laughter]
i can't find her if i'm in a house
i'm in a house i cannot find her for
12 hours actually watching your guys's
relationship did i would say for both
sistine and i showed that you guys are
very very fun with each other no matter
what i have a lot more fun i have a lot
more fun with her than she has with me
i think no she i think mom's a little
fiery sometimes
really yeah
oh yeah really
mom's got a sharp tongue did you say
fiery
boy
she needs a hearing aid
there she goes there's that time
hey
we call mom the town crier
she is she's a nice word for being a big
mouse yes it is
everything
what she's a big mouth what are you
i wouldn't say i'm a big mouth no if
she's the big mouth what are you
i don't know baby i'm kind of like
certain i'm the insult it's all about
me
see it's all about me you guys that's
your that's your fallback position it's
all about me yeah yeah the worst thing
he's ever done was get an instagram
account it's made him even worse it's
like oh actually i enjoy it thank you no
i honestly think instagram is good for
you you're connecting with your younger
generation i'm going on tick tock next
oh god for sure
that's it now you've done it now you've
thrown down the ground that is
officially the most embarrassing thing
you can do yeah i really want you to
hear our tick
actually i don't even think he'll know
how to use i'm not teaching you i'm not
teaching i don't need to help anyone be
on youtube i'm going to keep posting
videos i can't get a tick tock coach
tick tock coach
i can't okay you know what jennifer
right
no no no next time
you said no that's it
she got you well that rules you're sorry
butt out
oh my god no but it's funny i actually
do love all of our dating stories dad
this was something we've been looking
forward to for the last 50 episodes and
i'm really really thankful that you came
on and did this this is like a really
big you were pretty well behaved yeah i
have to say it was not easy it was not
easy i could tell you're squirming and
you're ready
you're ready but thank you guys so much
for tuning in to our 50th episode of the
unwax podcast make sure you're
subscribed get ready to follow along on
our instagram our youtube page what else
are we on where can they find you
oh
my instagram did you just say that did
you just say that's a joke i'm being
sarcastic
i'm under it official slides alone on
instagram he's here
he said he's under hashtag
schwarzenegger
true okay cool but thank you guys for
tuning in and we will see you next week
say bye dad bye dad oh god
[Music]
you